und damit herzlich willkommen meine
lieben freunde zu einer neuen
wertvorstellung und zwar zu der disco
kraft modifikation die sehr sehr viele
coole neue items hinzufügt wie
beispielsweise diese disco dance floors
oder des kobolds die gaudi supercoole
effekte an eure wand in eurer tollen
disco zimmern die sich dann auch teils
bewegen und alles mögliche machen und
wir haben auch supertolle schallplatten
und was das alles ist das zeige ich euch
jetzt mal eben ganz kurz und zwar schon
drei kisten aufgebaut in einer welt in
der auf jeden fall jeder klub besitzer
super grip aufbauen würde weil hier sind
richtig viele party leute wir sehen da
oben schafe die unglaublichkeit in
diesen club leiten wollen sie sehen
schon richtig so aus als wollen party
machen die da unten auf die denkt sich
so ein klub aber hier als fahne sind ja
und wir haben jeden fall viele coole
neue themes wir sehen wer ins inventar
gehen
unter verschiedenes sehen wir hier unten
ganz ganz viele neue schallplatten wie
beispielsweise eine black music disc und
aus dieser kann man sich beispielsweise
von kevin mchale ihr team kennen
wahrscheinlich sehr viele von euch die
selber videos machen oder die sehr sehr
viele videos schauen sehr viele youtube
nutzen die musik von kevin mchale ich
habe dieselbe eine zeit lang -
mittlerweile benutze ich andere musik
von anderen leuten dabei relativ egal
jedenfalls ist diese musik copyright fri
das heißt wenn diese mod hat man die
macht darüber ein video braucht ihr da
nix sagen oder irgendwie sowas die dürft
ihr einfach zu benutzen da gibt es die
songs disco konnte die disco long china
disco over cast strings disco und
roubaix to party und dann habe ich ja
noch chips wie beispielsweise mit chip
oder einfach mehr zumal am meer oder
diese black music disc dann haben wir
hier noch unter so haben wir es dann
unter dekorationen haben wir hier noch
einen discoball und einen dancefloor und
unter redstone finden wir auch einen
app-store easy war das alles die atoms
hinzugefügt wurden
die kräfte man sich so wenn man acht
glas nimmt umrandet und eisenwaren packt
bekommt man einen mirror also ein
spiegel wenn ich den hut ihr seht schon
damit kann ich nichts macht und den kann
ich hier nichts dran placken das alles
hier aber noch bei mir so ein wenig weil
mein pc zu zeigen wie von viren befallen
ist
keine ahnung keine ahnung warum wenn wir
diesen mehr anhaben können wieder
einfach so in kraft im tablet packen
oder hierhin oder dahin da auch hier
oder auch hier aber ich mag einfach
damit bekommen wir neue mikrochips mit
diesem in chips zu so einem blog
anordnen wenn kräftig table bekommen wir
eine disco boys einen discoball das ist
er hier oben den könnte dann ganz
einfach dran zimmern und dann seht ihr
an der wand sind diese unterschiedlich
schnellen manchmal stoppten die wie
beispielsweise ich jetzt gerade jetzt
klingt da hier ganz kurz da sehen wir
jetzt stoppte zum beispiel und gleich
wenn irgendwie die musik weitergeht oder
keine ahnung woran das liegt gleich die
das auf jeden fall wieder weiter da seht
ihr da geht es schon wieder weiter
diese komische sache die wir dann an die
wand projiziert und wir können das ganze
auch nehmen und dann zwei hintereinander
drei packen oder 3 und dann haben wir
eine debatte bald relativ gut wir können
da noch einen pakt und da und da und
dann ist es manchmal auch so schnell
dass es einfach anhält und nein wir
lassen das einfach ich würde sagen ein
erreicht dass man findet das guck mal
ganze weg kann kommt zur zweiten kiste
und zwar einen redstone receiver den
macht man sich mit zwei eisen einen
goldbarren und redstone das geht
eigentlich relativ fit geht als relativ
leicht zu machen und diesem receiver
müssen wir mit steinen und einer
resterampe am rand und dann bekommen wir
vier dancefloors das sind die die wir
hier auf dem boden haben die seht ihr
die leuchtenden farben warte lila rot
grün blau lila rot grün blau oder rot
grün blau 54 verschiedene farben
die müssen allerdings gebaut werden ich
hab jetzt beispielsweise ein schalter
hin gepackt damit könnt ihr die bauern
ich nehme dir jetzt mal ganz kurz und
zeigt euch das mal ganz kurz hier wenn
ich jetzt nämlich beispielsweise okay
wir sind immer noch gebaut
ich mach das jetzt mal ganz kurz aus
die sind jetzt nämlich nicht mehr gebaut
ihr seht schon die sind genau in
entfernung bla bla bla bla ich könnte
jetzt hier irgendwie anordnen
so und jetzt könnte ich auch irgendwie
neue redstone fackeln die müssen
irgendwie gebaut werden und dann sind
die alle miteinander verbunden und sind
alle am leuchten allerdings ihr seht
schon die da vorne sind nicht mehr
leuchten also nur einem bestimmten
umkreis
wenn ich jetzt dieser redstone fackel
beispielsweise hier einsetzen würde
werdet ihr sehen dass das ganze
ebenfalls nicht funktioniert so das
heißt wir das ganze hier vorne jetzt mal
eben ganz gezeigt ich habe da hinten
einfach in die disco ich könnte
natürlich einfach damit jetzt habe ich
diese ewige musik annimmt das ist ja mal
so abartig wir könnten natürlich auch
einfach hier damit das ganze schöner
aussieht hier eine hinsetzen daran einen
dran und dann sieht das ganze auch viel
schöner aus dann hat man nicht mit
komischen lämmer drin
ich hab's allerdings nur gemacht damit
ihr das mal ganz kurz seht wie das ganze
überhaupt funktioniert so dass man auf
jeden fall diese dancefloors die man
sich halt mit dem receiver acht steinen
7 stand ein letzter nachgemacht und
jetzt kommt zu den discs die auch sehr
cool sind zwar brauchen wir drei
obsidian ist relativ teuer für eine
black music und dann brauchen wir sogar
noch den farbstoff beispielsweise mit
türkisen farbstoff bekommen wir diese
schallplatte ida disco dies also türkis
anhalt und wir können auch hier noch
andere sachen machen wir waren so waren
sie dann beispielsweise in girod nehmen
bekommen wir likes to party oder
irgendwie so und dann können wir
selbstverständlich einfach mal
plattenspieler eingeben dann lange
seinen plattenspieler dann mach ich mal
ganz kurz optionen machen wir eben die
ich weiß gar nicht mich dafür achten
habe ich sogar schon
dann können auf jeden fall richtig coole
party machen das sind so ein paar
verschiedene songs die hinzugefügt
werden ich zeige euch dass man hier noch
ganz kurz mal jeden einmal ganz kurz
durch aber ich bin auch ich habe extra
die kiste darauf gestellt mit den ganzen
sachen schon super vorbereitet dass sie
gibt nämlich auch noch
und die finde ich auch ganz cool
das ist so was wie ein horrorfilm
das ist finde ich keine party musik egal
die haben wir noch
wacker ist und wir haben auch noch ums
prinzip des gebens auf jeden fall ein
paar ganz coole sachen dabei werden halt
alle hier mit hinzugefügt braucht ihr
nix in die unterlagen nur die
modifikation und das ganze ist auf jeden
fall richtig geil und ihr könnt damit
richtig coole diskus herstellen vor
allem mit diesem discoball und alles
mögliche ich glaube das ganze
funktioniert auch auf servern ich bin
mir nicht sicher
ihr könnt alles auf der website
nachlesen die ich euch in der
beschreibung verlinkt habe ich würde
sagen ich mache jetzt noch richtig viel
party weil so coole musik dann hilft und
ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat
könnt ihr das ganze ist natürlich nur
eine modifikation es ist nichts was
etwas revolutionäres dazu hinzufügt aber
ich weiß nicht ich liebe diese motto
total abgefuckt scheiße sind also die
ist nicht besonders einfach so verrückt
deswegen wenn ihr mehr davon wollte
zeigt mit einer bewertung schreibt
eventuell muss in die kommentare das ist
mir ganz wichtig schreibt merz in die
kommentare die ich vorstellen soll
weil damit eventuell damit ich sehe was
ihr eventuell vorgestellt haben wollte
und dann